DEAD.
SHE IS NOW COHERENT, UNABLE TO
HOLD FULL LENGTH CONVERSATIONS.
>> Reporter: DANIEL PALMER III
WAS ANYTHING BUT COOPERATIVE, AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRIED TO GET HIM
TO JAIL AFTER AN INITIAL COURT
SPREEDING ON FRIDAY.
PALMER, IN JACKSON COUNTY, WEST
VIRGINIA, IS NOW CHARGED WITH
THE ATTEMPTED MURDER OF HIS
SISTER, WANDA, IN JUNE OF 2020.
ALLEGEDLY BLUDGEONING HER WITH A
HATCHET OR AX ACCORDING TO THE
SHERIFF.
IT WAS WANDA'S MOTHER WHO CALLED
911 AFTER IT HAPPENED.
>> THEY CAME WEDNESDAY MORNING
TO MOW HER GRASS, AND THEY FOUND
HER IN A BIG POOL OF BLOOD.
THEY RUN UP ON THE HILL REAL
FAST ON THE FOUR WHEELER AND
TOLD SKPUS I CALLED THE POLICE
AND THE AMBULANCE.
>> Reporter: WANDA WAS FOUND IN
HER LIVING ROOM.
>> WE SHOW UP AND SEE HER ON THE
COUCH BLOODY, BATTERED,
BLUDGEONED IN THE HEAD OR FACE
AREA.
>> Reporter: THEY BELIEVED SHE
WAS DEAD BUT THEN HEARD SOUNDS,
QUOTE, COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
THE DEATH RATTLE.
BUT WANDA WAS ALIVE.
>> I WOULDN'T HAVE WAGERED A
NICKEL FOR HER LIFE THIS
MORNING.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO THE
CRIMINAL COMPLAINT, A WITNESS
SAW WANDA'S BROTHER AT HER
TRAILER THAT NIGHT.
AND INVESTIGATORS SAY THERE WAS
A HISTORY OF VIOLENCE BETWEEN
THEM.
BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAD NO
WEAPON, NO EYEWITNESS TO THE
ATTACK, AND NO PHONE RECORDS OR
VIDEO.
AND WANDA WAS IN A COMA UNTIL
ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO, WHEN SHE
WOKE UP IN HER NURSING HOME, THE
SHERIFF SAYS.
AND SHE TOLD INVESTIGATORS THE
ATTACKER THAT NIGHT WAS HER OWN
BROTHER.
>> FOR HER TO BE ABLE TO WAKE UP
AND SAY, YOU KNOW, GIVE THE
NAME, THANK GOD.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
THANK GOD.
>> THIS CASE IS REALLY ALL ABOUT
THE PERSEVERANCE AND THE
TOUGHNESS AND THE STRENGTH OF
THE VICTIM IN ITSELF.
>> AND PALMER IS BEING HELD ON
$500,000 BAIL.
THE COURT CLERK'S OFFICE TOLD ME
TODAY THAT HE DOES NOT HAVE AN
ATTORNEY YET BECAUSE HE IS
REFUSING TO SIGN THE PAPERWORK.
AND ANDERSON, THE SHERIFF HAD
TOLD US EARLY ON THAT SHE WAS
ONLY ABLE TO GIVE ONE WORD
RESPONSES, YES OR NO TO ANY
QUESTION.
LATE TODAY, THEY'RE TELLING US
THAT SHE CAN DO PRIMITIVE
SPEAKING, GAVE US AN EXAMPLE.
WHY WOULD YOUR BROTHER WANT TO
DO THIS?
MEAN